Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt,
Mein Name ist Tim Pritla und ihr hört UKW Corona Weekly, unsere wöchentliche Ausgabe rund um die Corona-Krise, um Zahlen, um Fakten, um Verschwörung und das volle Programm.
Mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Versuchen wie jede Woche in irgendeiner Form dieses ganze Informationsgewitter um uns herum äh aufzufangen und zu analysieren, was da so drin enthalten ist,
Ja, auf den genetischen Code der Krise sind wir noch nicht gekommen, aber ist auch irgendwie in zunehmenden Maße schwierig. Ich habe vor allem auch das Gefühl, gerade.
Es verschwimmt jetzt auch alles. Also während wir so monatelang ähm also vor einem Jahr und dann halt noch mal im Winter so in diesen dicken Wellen,
eine vergleichsweise fokussierte Diskussion hatten dahingehend, dass.
Gesellschaft darüber redet, ja? Ist es halt jetzt Punkt fünf in der Tagesschau.
So, ja, Israelbomben hier, Weltgeschehen, irgendwie normale Dinge passieren, auch äh normale unschöne Dinge passieren. Und dann so, ach ja, Corona. So und ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut ist oder nicht. Ähm.
Auf jeden Fall ist es auch ein bisschen schwierig dadurch geworden, glaube ich, so ein bisschen rauszufinden, was eigentlich,
am meisten Relevanz hat, also worüber eigentlich woran eigentlich noch am meisten Interesse besteht im Rahmen dieser ganzen Diskussion.
Ja ich weiß nicht fand durch die Clubhaus Feedback Runden habe ich da schon so einen äh gewissen
Eindruck äh so, ich meine, das das schwenkt halt immer ein bisschen und im Moment äh glaube ich äh ist das Thema.
Impfen äh.
Man, glaube ich, gesehen, also rund rund ums Impfen und auch neue Aspekte jetzt der Impfung äh so, dass das fand ich ganz.
Ganz gut, nämlich die Frage dann auch, okay, wie lange halten jetzt die Impfungen und Impfpass und diese ganzen äh äh Sachen und wie wie sicher bin ich eigentlich, wenn ich geimpft bin und äh so, wann können wir denn,
lockern, wenn wie viel Leute geimpft sind. Das ist sind, glaube ich, jetzt so im Moment die Punkte, wo sich, glaube ich, viel Interesse drauf,
konzentriert oder.
Ja, da stimme ich dir zu, was äh sagen wir mal, unsere Bubble hier auch konkret betrifft
ist das mit Sicherheit so ich meinte auch eher so ein bisschen mehr so auf der Ebene so die Interpretation von allem irgendwie so geht's uns jetzt eigentlich gut, geht's uns jetzt eigentlich schlecht? Äh.
Wo befinden wir uns eigentlich gerade so ein bisschen so in dieses ja ist jetzt eigentlich noch Krise oder oder oder ist schon irgendwie vorbei
heißt das Gefühl, dass das weicht so ein bisschen auf, weil weil das irgendwie alles auch keiner mehr so richtig wahrhaben will. Und das leider noch bei etwas zu hohen Inzidenzen, auf die Zahlen kommen wir aber
heute ein bisschen später, denn wir wollen mal ein bisschen äh mit Feedback anfangen.
Weil's eine Menge äh Kommentare gab zur letzten Sendung. Ähm unter anderem.
Sind wir jetzt ähm haben wir uns äh angeblich rassistisch geäußert oder du hast dich rassistisch geäußert.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich traue den Chinesen nicht.
Und ich habe jetzt überlegt, ob ich besser gesagt hätte, ich traue China nicht, aber ich ich traue weder China noch den Chinesen und ich kann,
das vielleicht ein bisschen besser ausführen, das war auch beim letzten Mal ziemlich gegen Ende der der Sendung, aber
dieser Aussage, ich traue den Chinesen nicht, habe ich halt wegen salopp äh gemeint, dass sowohl die Menschen dort,
als auch das System, in dem die Menschen äh leben, einfach sehr, sehr,
anders äh sind, als wir, die ticken einfach anders und funktionieren anders und denken anders und haben andere Prioritäten.
Als Kollektiv, meinst du jetzt oder äh.
Als Kollektiv und individuell, also äh zum einen ich sage mal, ist dort wie in vielen anderen kommunistischen
Ländern auch, aber besonders in China halt durch die Kultur äh Revolution ist äh dort eine ganze Generation von Menschen auch
auf eine Art und Weise sozial dysfunktional äh äh geworden so,
weil ich mein Motto der Kulturrevolution war, halt eben unter anderem Lehrern nicht zu vertrauen, ja, also allen Autoritäten, insbesondere intellektuellen äh nicht zu vertrauen
und ähm ja, äh das hat halt äh das hatte halt einfach keine guten Folgen, die,
heute eben noch andauern. Dann, was auch äh so hinweg
oder worüber die Bilder von diesem sich entwickelnden China äh und diesen ganzen aus dem
ja schnell entstehenden, großen Städte und so, diese ganze Dynamik, was die überdeckt ist, dass in
ganz, ganz weiten Teilen äh des Landes halt extreme Armut herrscht.
Die Lebensbedingungen eben dort auch noch was äh ganz anders sind und dann und das ist das sozusagen, da kommt jetzt mein Misstrauen her, ist
es dort äh ja in China noch das Individuum einen anderen Stellenwert
hat äh als bei uns so mehr wie früher auch bei den alten Germanen äh war's auch noch so, dass äh eben Geld wichtiger ist als Leben,
und äh ja haben wichtiger als sein. Es ist zwar jetzt nicht so ganz krass, äh wie bei den ähm,
Germanen äh so, aber da spiegelte sich das dann halt auch im Rechtssystem wieder, dass auf Mord, Geldstrafe stand typischerweise,
und für Vermögensdelikte ist aber häufig die Todesstrafe gab, also Diebstahl von einem.
Oder so, während du halt für Mord je nachdem, ob das jetzt äh irgendwie
ein Alter, Mensch oder ein Junger oder eine Frau äh war bei wenn du eine schwangere Frau getötet hast, dann äh hing die Höhe der Geldstrafe davon ab, welches Geschlecht der Fötus
hatte.
Bei den Germanen.
Bei den Germanen, genau. Und äh ich meine, auch wenn das bei den Chinesen nicht ganz so krass ist, mehr heute, äh aber
sondern anderes Ding, ich mein bis zwanzig fünfzehn wurden noch Zwangsabtreibungen im siebten und achten Monat vorgenommen in,
in China gegen den Willen der Frauen wegen der Ein-Kind-Politik zum Beispiel.
So was prägt natürlich eine Gesellschaft und die ja, die Leute verhalten sich einfach ganz, ganz anders. Die haben halt ganz, ganz andere Werte und weil eben Geld,
auch äh so eine, so eine wichtige Rolle spielt. So ist, muss man halt äh einfach bei Transaktionen höllisch aufpassen. Also du mit.
Mit China oder weil du kannst dich eben nicht darauf verlassen, dass bestimmte Regeln, äh die wir bei uns jetzt so, ja,
intrinsisch beachten, die gelten dort einfach nicht. Ja und ähm.
Deswegen äh ja, ich meine, das wird irgendwann werden die Chinesen sich hoffentlich auch äh,
weiterentwickeln, eben kulturell äh und und so, also im Sinne von jetzt vielleicht einer,
freiheitlicheren äh äh Kultur oder Wahrung äh von Menschenrechten, aber ich meine, bei uns hat ja, wie wir gesehen haben, ein Menschenleben auch nur so, wenn's ums Große und Ganze geht, im im System,
auch jetzt nicht so einen absoluten Stellenwert äh wie äh man uns das äh weiß machen möchte, aber in China ist es einfach nochmal um,
krasser, ja, da ist, zählt der Einzelne einfach nicht viel.
Trotzdem hat sich äh das Land sehr viel intensiver um die Bekämpfung der Pandemie bemüht als wir.
Das hat dort äh aber auch unter anderem äh deswegen äh funktioniert ähm.
So weniger, also es ging, glaube ich, dort weniger um den Schutz äh jetzt der einzelnen Menschen, sondern auch um den Schutz des Systems,
einfach die haben halt erkannt, im Gegensatz zu uns
dass diese Pandemie nicht nur den Menschen schadet, sondern vor allen Dingen eine Gefahr für das System darstellt. Und in dem Moment hat unser System ja auch agiert, dann muss man sagen, in dem Moment, wo.
Die Intensivstation drohten überzulaufen und das System in Gefahr war, ja? Da hat das System dann auch reagiert.
So, aber nicht so, also solange, ich sage mal, nur einzelne Leute gestorben sind, äh so äh viel die Reaktion dann erstmal ähm verhalten aus.
Nach dem Motto, was wollte denn, es ist doch noch Platz in den Intensivstation.
Genau, genau. Und das ist und,
bei der ersten äh Welle war's halt anders, da fühlte sich das System eben auch bedroht, weil man gesehen hat, Italien und so, also und mit System meine ich jetzt äh so das Zusammenspiel aus ähm,
ja, sag mal, Gesellschaft, Politik und Staat, so dieses, dieses ganze Zusammenspiel. Das meine ich mit,
System und das hat halt so seine eigene Dynamik, die,
niemand einzelner wirklich steuern kann und das hat halt auch eine,
Intelligenz und Gedächtnis, also man kann das quasi wie so ein eigenes Wesen sehen, was irgendwie auch vor sich hindenkt und agiert und reagiert, wie
Keine Ahnung, wie so ein Ameisen, wie eine Ameisenkolonie im Prinzip, bloß komplizierter.
Also die Intelligenz äh äh bei Ameisen steckt halt auch nicht in der einzelnen Ameise, sondern die ist halt so eine kollektive verteilte Intelligenz. Deswegen äh
Ja und so ist halt eben auch
Systemgesellschaft ist halt einfach nochmal viel, viel intelligenter und mächtiger als jeder einzelne von uns und hat auch eigene Interessen und ein Eigenleben.
Ja, ich denke, man muss jetzt aber schon doch ein bisschen unterscheiden, ne, weil äh,
ist immer ein bisschen problematisch ist, wenn man von so großen Gruppen, insbesondere von so großen Gruppen wie äh der chinesischen Bevölkerung äh spricht, dass man so locker allein in China schon eins Komma drei Milliarden und dann haben wir noch ein paar auf der ganzen Welt.
Genau, weswegen ich ich rede, ich sage mal dort auch, äh was ich dort meine mit ist das System China.
Mit sowohl seinen Individuen, mit seinen gesellschaftlichen Strukturen, mit,
den staatlichen Strukturen und ja, ich meine, ja, wer traut denn, äh sagen, ich traue der kommunistischen Partei China
dass sie 'nen guten Job,
ich würde mir wünschen, dass wir hier auch, dass die vielleicht auch hier in Deutschland ähm übernehmen würde oder eine ähnliche Einheitspartei oder so.
Bei den Querdenkern bestimmt ein paar Leute, die da noch mit ein.
Genau.
Würden irgendwie sind ja auch große Freunde vom russischen System.
Gut, wir hatten ja diesen, diesen Punkt, um China im Kontext dieser Medikamenten und Patente Diskussion geführt und darauf sollten wir dann vielleicht auch nochmal äh weiter äh gehen, so diese grundsätzliche Frage.
Okay, was was sind denn jetzt hier.
Puncto Debatte Öffnung von Patenten, was denn hier äh ein ein richtiger funktionierender und gewinnbringender äh Weg und was sind halt die Interessen anderer Länder. Ne, ich glaube, in dem Zusammenhang hatten wir das.
Zu den Patenten gab's natürlich auch eine ganze Menge andere Meinungen in ähm.
In den Kommentaren, gab auch ein paar interessante Links, vielleicht nicht alle durchgelesen habe, aber versucht so ein bisschen auch ein bisschen mehr zu verstehen, was eigentlich hier so läuft. Das, was ja konkret diskutiert wird, wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe.
Äh also was dieser Vorschlag von Präsident Biden umfasst ist ein sogenannter Trips Vava, also ein Aussitzen eines Abkommens namens.
Das steht für und das ist im Prinzip so.
Der einer von drei Pfeilern, auf denen dieses Gesamtrechtsgebilde der World Trade Organisation der WTO äh sitzt.
Andere etwas bekanntere Abkürzungen sind die anderen beiden Pfeiler gut. Äh das bezieht sich auf die äh Regelung für den ganzen Warenverkehr.
Und eben Dienstleistung, Gatz. Und das ist so im Prinzip so eine Art,
Na ja, Grundregeln für internationalen Freihandel. Also wenn man in irgendeiner Form
von Land zu Land Handel betreiben will und man hat keine anderen Regelungen, dann greifen halt auf jeden Fall erstmal die WTO-Regel und sonst macht man halt bei diesem ganzen WTO-Spaß nicht mit und wenn man beim WTO-Spaß nicht mitmacht, dann.
Ist man sozusagen komplett draußen so.
Mehr als. Ja, das ist, dass man dann äh ja, ich glaube, Nordkorea.
Ja nee, ich glaube, so dieses einzige Land, was irgendwie also kaum ein Land muss sich komplett auf diese WTO-Regeln,
verlassen und hat nichts anderes, ja? Es gibt natürlich zahlreiche andere Abkommen, insbesondere, was so die EU mit der Welt hat, da sind da die totalen Weltmeister
Aber das ist so quasi so der das Basic Principle und so der und ähm das ist halt schon vor einiger Zeit umgesetzt worden. Auf jeden Fall in diesem ganzen Trips
abkurben, da stecken halt diese ganzen sogenannten drin, so der Name, also Patente, umfasst das halt genauso wie auch Aspekte von Urheberrecht.
Et cetera,
und ein viral in dem Fall eben dieses diskutierte Aussetzen, was sich wohl in diesem Fall vor allem auf diese Patentfrage beziehen soll.
Das ist sozusagen das, was äh in der Debatte äh ist, was Medikamente betrifft,
sieht das äh aus meiner Perspektive so aus. Es gibt da durchaus in Trips schon entsprechende Formulierungen.
Die durchaus sowas wie eine Zwangslizenzierung von äh Patenten vorsieht im Bereich von Medikamenten vor allem, ja, das bezieht sich äh,
primär diese ganze Debatte bezog sich primär bisher auch so auf Generika, also auf so einfache Medikamente, die,
man einfach mal so herstellen kann und die andere Leute irgendwie äh auch gerne hätten, aber vom freien Markt nicht bezahlen können
Aids-Medikamente zum Beispiel waren ein starkes Thema. Südafrika ist da wohl auch schon mal vorgeprescht, da gab's dann sehr viel Aufregung und Widerstand und.
Zweitausendeins vor zwanzig Jahren gab's dann noch so ein zusätzliches Doha-Abkommen, in dem äh das auch nochmal ein bisschen gelockert worden.
Ist, allerdings ist die Druckkulisse äh für entsprechende Bestrafung und äh Boykott-Maßnahmen anderer Länder,
immer noch relativ groß und von daher wird dieses Instrument wohl kaum genutzt. So habe ich's in etwa verstanden. Die Meinung darüber, ob halt jetzt.
Patente generell eine gute Idee sind oder nicht, das hatten wir ja letztes Mal auch schon besprochen, dass es äh ist so das eine und das andere ist natürlich die Frage, wie wir jetzt in der aktuellen Situation damit umgehen sollen.
Das ist das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt, glaube ich, den viele auch bei meinem Tweet, den ich abgegeben habe, auch aber auch, glaube ich, viele, die hier kommentiert haben, nicht,
so genau gemacht haben oder ähm ich sage mal zwischen den beiden Situationen bisschen vermischt haben. Unsere Statements
haben sich jetzt konkret auf die aktuelle Situation bezogen, nämlich hilft es jetzt.
Diese Würde so einen Trips helfen. Hm.
In der momentanen Situation äh die Welt schneller und besser mit Impfstoffen so versorgen, dass die eine Sache und die andere Sache, da kann man dann.
Auch noch kurz drüber reden ist klar zu stellen was denn nach unserer Sicht oder nach meiner Sicht, deiner Sicht nachdem die langfristig wünschenswerte Situation so bei,
Urheberrechten, Patentrechten, geistigen Eigentum eigentlich wäre. Genau und,
man in dem Zusammenhang äh sowohl in den Kommentaren, als auch Twitter äh wurde dann,
nochmal gefragt äh wie denn äh sagen unsere Sicht,
sich jetzt mit einem Artikel von Korry Doctorov auf äh Medium.
Verträgt, wo er im Wesentlichen geschrieben hat, äh ja, also der,
Titel von dem Artikel heißt Manufacturing ähm
und äh ja äh,
Herstellung von RNA wachsen ist überraschend, ja straight forward äh vielleicht mit.
Man will einfach sagen, oh heißt nicht genau einfach ein gradliniger Weg äh also absehbar unter komplex oder so.
Ja ja ich gucke gucke gerade mal, was denn äh so das Internet sagt, was denn.
Wie man's noch äh übersetzen kann. Meinst.
Einfach, ja, sie.
Ja, es ist überschaubar, unkompliziert. Ähm ja, schnörkellos.
Gut.
So und ja, wenn man in der Interpretation unkompliziert würde ich jetzt äh nicht wirklich mitgehen, aber wo,
er wahrscheinlich recht hat und er bezieht sich da jetzt äh auch auf.
Andere äh äh Gruppen wie auch äh WTO und ähm,
ja die Einschätzung auch von Technikern, dass es einfacher ist, eine M RNA Produktion aufzubauen als sag mal eine klassische Impfstoffproduktion, dass sie sich auf,
deutlich weniger Raum und mit deutlich weniger Material bewerkstelligen lässt.
Zweifele ich jetzt auch nicht an, aber ähm so ich,
sehe aber nicht, ähm dass das jetzt an meiner Meinung oder Haltung äh zu dem, was wir bisher gesagt haben, etwas ändern würde, nämlich dass es,
halt äh gerade im Moment eben nicht so einfach ist. Und ähm weil,
die Technologie ist halt nur eine Sache äh oder ein Problem an der Impfstoffproduktion. Ähm,
was dieser Artikel so ein bisschen außen vor äh lässt, ist halt die Frage der Basisstoffe und die der Qualitätskontrolle und,
die ganze Erprobung äh der Impfstoffe und Dokumentationen äh der Erprobung, dass ja all,
gesehen haben, sind die kapitalintensiven Dinge und brauchen auch funktionierende Verwaltungsstrukturen,
sonst äh ja, wird's halt schwierig. Also Technologie ist halt nun Teil im Moment und wir sehen ja auch.
Dass äh gerade selbst viele andere große Pharmakonzerne.
Probleme haben äh oder nicht das Know-How und die Experten haben, um da mal eben mit schnell einzusteigen, ja.
Sondern äh ich meine, die versuchen alle einzusteigen, aber selbst selbst die Leute, wo es eigentlich nicht an Kapital und Know-how und
äh was man sonst noch so braucht, äh eigentlich fehlt und die Sachen problemlos in Lizenz produzieren könnten. Ich meine, was da auch teilweise gemacht wird, aber wir sehen ja
wie lange das dann selbst bei uns dauert so mit 'ner technologischen Basis. Was wir aber ja auch erfahren haben.
In ähm im letzten äh Klapphaus äh war von jemandem, der.
Dort mitarbeitet ähm an ja ähm direkt diesen ähm RNA Impfstoffen und dort forscht es, dass.
Es wohl Geräte geben wird, die ganz viel von dem notwendigen Know-How einfach in Software enthalten.
Werden. So und das wird dann wahrscheinlich mittelfristig ist dann durchaus ermöglichen auch.
Tatsächlich diese Vorteile zu realisieren, dass es eben ähm ja.
Einfacher ist oder einfacher automatisierbar ist, auch der ganze ähm RNA Impfstoff äh Prozess,
Du wirst dann wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch ähm spezielle, definierte Grundstoffe äh brauchen, die dann
trotzdem noch wieder großtechnisch äh hergestellt sind. Also es ist nicht so, dass du dir dann ähm irgendwo einen einen Parkcontainer hinstellst und ein paar Maschinen und die
machen dann Impfstoff aus Luft und Wasser oder so, also so äh geht es halt auch nicht, sondern das Meer dann
wie so ein Drucker halt, wo du dann eben auch Druckerpatronen brauchst oder weiß ich nicht, Toner brauchst
den du da einfüllen musst und äh kannst dann aber eben der Unterschied ist, so wie du mitm Drucker verschiedene Sachen drucken kannst, kannst du dann halt mit diesen Geräten dann eben auch verschiedene Impfstoffe äh äh machen.
Und auch andere Sachen. Ich meine, das ist im Prinzip ja äh wovon wir, glaube ich, primär reden, ist, glaube ich, das woran Qwec arbeitet. Ist ja das Unternehmen, dessen Impfstoff,
jetzt so von allen demnächst mal erwartet wird, dass der äh Zulassung erfährt.
Ähm ich rechne mehr oder weniger täglich hier mit Ankündigungen. Ich weiß gerade nicht ganz genau, welcher Zeitplan da ist. Auf jeden Fall,
die Firma von Ingmar Hör, der eigentlich der erste war, der quasi diese RNA Produktion.
Im Körper so erforscht und erkannt hat,
eigentlich diese Revolution angetrieben und das ist ja auch alles noch nicht so lange her, das ist irgendwie etwas mehr als zwanzig Jahre her in Tübingen
und der hat dann halt äh gegründet und sich ja lange Zeit auch Schwierigkeiten gehabt äh mit dem Unternehmen in irgendeiner Form voranzukommen, weil die eben relativ wenig Geld hatten.
Und äh gerade jetzt letztes Jahr, als es halt in diese Pandemiephase ging, hat er ja einen Schlaganfall und ist dann äh genau, als es so drum ging, zukünftige Impfstoffe und Prozesse auszuhandeln, äh war die Firma quasi
auf einmal das ist nicht der Punkt, sondern ähm einerseits haben sie halt auch diese RMRNA-Technik voran gebracht und,
halten da sicherlich auch einige Patente, das weiß ich im Einzelnen nicht, bin mir aber relativ sicher, dass dem so ist. Ähm und sie arbeiten auch vor allem von Anfang an an dieser Automatisierung. Und da arbeiten sie interessanterweise mit Tesla zusammen mittlerweile,
äh ist halt deshalb so, weil Tesla diese Firma gekauft hat, deswegen heißt die jetzt Tesla äh Automation. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, äh wie die vorher hießen.
Ähm,
Ist halt eigentlich eine deutsches äh Unternehmen und arbeitet dann halt mit ähm also Tesla, Groman, Automation heißen sie offiziell als Groman hieß das Unternehmen vorher.
Und äh ja, die wollte irgendwie sonst keiner, Tesla hat die sich halt einfach mal geschnappt, aus welchen Gründen auch äh immer. Ich glaube, die sind auch im Automatisierungsbereich für den äh Fahrzeugbau äh relativ wichtig.
Steckt da jetzt nicht zu tief drin. Auf jeden Fall sind sie auch in dieser Automatisierung dieser dieses RNA-Printers, den da entwickelt äh engagiert. Und das ist halt so die Idee, dass man eben mit der MRNA Technologie
quasi das wirklich mehr oder weniger softwarebasiert macht. Das heißt, man gewinnt seine Informationen so, ja, welches Protein hätten wir denn gern? Ja, was soll denn gebaut werden?
Was soll denn der Körper jetzt mal produzieren, um sich gegen irgendwas zu wehren? Und das kann halt sowohl eben jetzt so eine Situation sein wie jetzt
A Virus, da brauchen wir dann mal hier die entsprechenden Bestandteile, an denen das Immunsystem das Virus erkennt, wenn es denn aufschlägt.
Oder eben auch, wo sie sich ja von der Forschung her mehr drauf konzentriert haben.
So Sachen wie äh sehr persönlich angepasste Krebsbekämpfung, ja, dass man Proben nimmt von äh einer Krebszelle oder mehreren Krebszellen in einem Körper von jemandem, der,
Krebs leidet und dann zusieht, dass man eben ein bestimmtes äh Protein produziert ähm oder.
Erstmal erkennt, äh was dann in der Lage ist, diesen Krebs zu bekämpfen oder das Immunsystem quasi auf dieses,
auf diesen Krebs zu trainieren, so ähnlich wie beim Impfen, bloß in dem Fall halt nicht für alle, sondern eben nur für eine einzige Person, sodass man eben ein hochpersonalisiertes Medikament quasi herstellt, aber man lässt es halt vom Körper,
selbst herstellen und liefert in diesem Print da eigentlich nur die Beschreibung, was denn gebraucht wird
dann wird diese MRNA genauso wie das jetzt mit den Impfstoffen auch ist, in so einer Lipidhülle in den Körper äh versenkt und bringt dann den Körper dazu
das entsprechende Medikament in Anführungsstrichen selber zu produzieren. Das ist also durchaus eine Zukunft, auf die wir jetzt blicken, aber die ist halt noch nicht da.
Abgefahren und ja ähm.
Und in dem Zusammenhang, ich meine, wie es auch grade erwähnt hast, fand ich's doch recht auffällig, dass,
alle Firmen, die jetzt da Champions äh sind, also auch als auch moderner hat ein riesige Probleme, irgendwie äh
Finanzierung äh zu kriegen. Ich weiß nur bei,
ähm bei Bayerntech äh war's dann mehr oder weniger ein Privatinvestment
was die über Wasser gehalten hat und die haben auch wirklich nicht viel Geld gehabt in den letzten Jahrzehnten irgendwie
äh da hatten wir halt auch, weiß ich nicht, so fünfzig Millionen Euro oder so für äh,
und also ja, das ist nicht so, dass man dass das jetzt irgendwie Konzerne gewesen wären oder Startups, die jetzt mit äh äh Geld überhäuft äh worden wären. Und ähm,
dass.
Vor dem vor dem Hintergrund äh jetzt der gesamten Patentdebatte, zu der ich halt auch noch ein bisschen was
loswerden wollte und sagen, also aktuelle Situation, wie gesagt, halte ich nach wie vor für
diesen diesen Trips für ja eine Nebelkerze äh mehr oder weniger, die
äh ja äh jetzt nicht wirklich Nutzen entfaltet, außer.
Dann wenn man das so betrachtet als kleinen Sieg oder Weg in Richtung jetzt Aufweichung des Trips.
Commons. So könnte das mein als diesen politischen Vorstoß könnte man das jetzt.
Interpretieren so, aber praktisch äh glaube ich bin ich nach wie vor davon überzeugt, wird uns das jetzt nicht helfen.
Ähm die.
Sache ist aber äh wie gesagt, allein, dass diese Firmen, äh die uns, die jetzt so wichtig sind, fast alle nicht überlebt hätten,
und wer weiß, wie viele Firmen äh die ja noch geilere Dinge hätten tun können oder noch bessere oder wie viele Medikamente es gibt,
gerade nicht entwickelt werden, weil unsere Gesellschaft äh halt,
und Ressourcen lieber woanders aluziiert, als dort. Und dieses Problem,
Patente so ein bisschen äh lindern, also äh oder Idee von Patenten und generell Urheberrechten.
Ist ja ähm dass wir dadurch davon profitieren, äh dass wir dann mehr und bessere Technologie haben, und so,
aber der.
Stand der Forschung äh die allgemeine Forschungsmeinung zum Thema ist, äh was bringen Patente, ist äh Non-Liquid. Also,
wir wissen es nicht, ein gesellschaftlicher Nutzen von gegenwärtigen Urheber und Patentrecht ist nicht nachweisbar
kann aber auch nicht ausgeschlossen werden, ja? Das ist sagen die Mehrheitsmeinung und.
Wenn es das Patentrecht nicht schon gebe, würde es mal nach heutigem Stand der Wissenschaft auch nicht einführen und das Urheberrecht auch nicht.
So, ja, also sagen die, die Indizien sind nicht so äh äh dass äh ja, man heute das nochmal machen äh würde, aber.
Warum denkst du das?
Äh nee, das ist der Stand der Forschung, weil man einfach
äh äh sagt, ähm also man weiß halt oder die allgemeine Meinung ist, dass nicht ein einziges bedeutendes Werk und nicht eine einzige wichtige Erfindung ist nicht gegeben hätte,
ohne Patente oder Urheberrechte, ja? So, also es gibt halt schlichtweg keinen Beweis dafür
äh das äh wie auch irgendwie damals schon sagte, dass die Möglichkeit der Patentierung von Erfindungen tatsächlich den Strom neuen technischen Wissens vergrößert äh oder nicht nur zu einer verschwenderischen Konzentration der Forschungstätigkeit,
auf Probleme führt, deren Lösung in naher Zukunft abzusehen ist so. Also ähm.
Meinst du jetzt?
FA von äh.
Friedrich August von Hayek.
Genau. So und äh ja, also mit anderen Worten ähm,
Ja, man kann sich jetzt man kann jetzt Befürworter oder Gegner sein, ähm aber keiner von beiden hat eben die Forschung äh auf seiner Seite
ja. Also wer wer behauptet irgendwie Patente wären toll äh so äh gibt's keinen Beweis für und äh wer aber sagt, Patente sind schädlich oder nutzlos äh
kann's auch nicht nachweisen, aber Fakt ist, wir haben nun mal jetzt dieses,
System irgendwann geschaffen und wie mit vielen anderen Dingen äh haben wir das jetzt und müssen jetzt irgendwie damit klarkommen. Also wir können's auch nicht.
Von einem mal aufs andere abschaffen, aber was wir halt tun können einfach.
Also das Patenzsystem stellt jetzt eigentlich auch kein Problem dar, also kein, kein wirkliches Problem. Insofern, dass,
der Staat jederzeit in der Lage ist.
Ja, äh bestimmte Dinge zu fördern, äh Ressourcen bereitzustellen, so und Sachen zu finanzieren und äh und wie man auch sieht, ist es auch erforderlich. Also das Patentrecht alleine
ist halt kein Anreiz dafür,
welche Dinge zu erfinden äh oder Geld in irgendetwas zu investieren, ja. Äh selbst wenn es die Investitionen möglicherweise im Nachgang schützt
So äh habe ich äh das noch nicht, noch nicht wirklich erlebt. Also ja, es äh und Patente können halt helfen,
dann Geld zu beschaffen, wenn man sie denn erstmal hat, aber ähm so eigentlich äh ist ja das Prinzip hm,
Das äh oder man braucht das Geld ja vorher. So mit dem, ja, äh um, um, um was zu erfinden, äh, ja. Und ich kenne halt auch eigentlich keine Erfinder oder so, äh die,
jetzt ähm irgendwie Dinge bauen, äh damit sie hinterher patentierbar sind, ja, sondern der der Anlass oder die Motivation, etwas zu erfinden, geht nicht von von Patenten aus.
Das gibt's halt nicht. Also äh und insofern jetzt.
Wenn ich die Regeln jetzt machen würde oder wenn.
Ich jetzt überlegen würde, was wären denn bessere Regeln.
Dann ähm, ich meine, das ist ein riesen Fass, da kann man gerne in meinen eigenen Podcast äh zu zu machen, zum Thema Eigentum und Eigentumsrecht und wie man das alles besser umgestalten kann,
aber ähm ja äh grundsätzlich äh äh brauchen wir halt einen einen System, was eben.
Bestimmte Dinge, ja, wie man schon sagt, den Strom neuen technischen Wissens oder eben mehr Impfstoffe, mehr,
mehr Grundlagen. Das ist einfach eine gesellschaftliche Aufgabe. Das ist eine Staatsaufgabe
ja, das kann privatwirtschaftlich kann man das nicht gut organisieren und es gibt eigentlich auch, ich kenne keine Start-ups, äh die jemals irgendwas äh äh wirklich,
erfunden hätten. Ja, also wo,
also aus den letzten zwanzig oder oder dreißig Jahren äh wo irgendwie jetzt bahnbrechende Erkenntnisse oder Methoden oder so, sondern das hatte halt alles andere Hintergründe und äh ohnehin ja.
Elon Musk gefällt mir, weil du gerade vorhin auch noch Elon Musk erwähntest. Ähm du weißt, dass Elon Muskler nicht gegründet hat,
und auch sonst eigentlich von den ganzen Firmen man ihnen nachsagt, dass er die gegründet hätte, hat er nicht gegründet und er hatte auch nicht die Idee, jetzt irgendwie ein schnelles Elektroauto zu bauen und er hat es auch nicht gebaut. Äh
so, sondern das waren andere, die ja dann aus der Firma rausgekantet hat. Ähm.
Und ansonsten und es ist halt halt auch äh äh weiß ich nicht. Ähm wenn ich mir das, also nachdem was ich jetzt so noch an Hintergründen äh noch noch gehört habe,
ähm mache ich mir echte Sorgen um die Fabrik hier in in Brandenburg, ob die jemals Autos produzieren wird.
Ja, weil.
Ich meine, die die Tesla ist auch einfach strukturell so, äh ist im Vergleich zu anderen Automobilfirmen auch, ich weiß nicht, überhaupt zu,
zu allen Firmen, also nicht mal nicht mal irgendwie Amazon oder oder Apple oder Google haben ein.
Ja dermaßen schlechtes Verhältnis an an,
Kennzahlen von, ich sage mal, egal, ob du Umsatz, ich mein Gewinn sowieso nicht, also Dividende zahlt Tesla ja ohnehin nicht, ähm aber,
ja, ansonsten ist halt ungefähr,
der der Kurs von Tesla, ich glaube, zwischen Faktor hundert und tausend, je nachdem, wie man's rechnet, aufgeblasen, das heißt, wenn du,
jetzt äh ja und also das da ist ist eine riesige Blase um um Elon Musk herum, die vielleicht platzen wird, aber egal.
Ich glaube, da können wir dann nochmal einen anderen Podcast zu machen. Äh lass uns ein bisschen bei den Patenten bleiben oder beziehungsweise diesen Punkt vielleicht auch mal äh zum Abschluss bringen. Ähm also.
Grundfrage ist oder die Grundfrage.
Patente eine gute Sache oder eine schlechte Sache sind, lässt sich jetzt von uns hier an dieser Stelle so auch nicht beantworten.
Es gibt Zweifel daran, es mag auch Dinge geben, die dafür sprechen, sie sind nur eine Realität, sind sozusagen sie existieren, sie sind da und sie beherrschen natürlich das Wirtschaftsgeschehen, so wie es heute
ist und alle Strukturen, mit denen wir derzeit agieren,
basieren auf der auf dem Vorhandensein dieses Systems, denn sie sind ja letzten Endes nichts anderes als die Konsequenz aus äh der rechtlichen äh Realität, die wir nun mal haben. So und dann ist eben die Frage, was ist jetzt in dieser Situation,
das sinnvolle. Vielleicht können wir damit ja nochmal schließen. Ähm ich bin auch so in diesem.
Nicht überzeugt davon, dass jetzt hier irgendwelche kurzfristige Anpassungen und Ausnahmen und Wavors viel bringen würden. Aber was bedeutet denn für die Zeit der Pandemie.
Wie ist sie denn definiert? Wer wer macht das dann die World Health Organisation? Die beschließt dann, wann sozusagen eine Regel der World Trade Organisation nicht mehr äh gilt. Hm,
ist das dann in sechs Monaten, ist das irgendwie in in sechs Jahren?
Ist es, wenn das Virus äh ausgerottet ist oder nicht, also das finde ich ein bisschen unklar.
Und äh ja und egal, ob das dann jetzt ich sage mal, eine eine staatliche Organisation ist oder eine Firma, die sich dann.
Equipment meinetwegen zulegt und so eine Produktion aufbaut ähm.
Ja was machen die denn damit, wenn die Pandemie zu Ende ist? Dürfen sie dann alles verschrotten oder.
Dann müssen sich dann irgendwie aus 'ner schlechten Verhandlungsposition heraus, um 'ne Lizenz bemühen, weil immer.
Die Firmen wissen dann natürlich, man hat halt das Equipment jetzt schon da stehen, das heißt äh
ja, es ist eine andere Verhandlungssituation, als als wenn ich äh hingehe zu einer Firma und sage, ich möchte halt jetzt gerne irgendwas in Lizenz produzieren äh äh von von euch,
Ähm aber ja ähm.
Also entweder, ich meine, ein ein Weg ist und mein, die USA wären auch die Ersten, äh wenn die irgendwas brauchen, äh dann äh nehmen die sich das, ja? Äh vor allen Dingen,
aber es wird dann halt eben entsprechend der Erfinder auch entschädigt und eigentlich bräuchte man nur eine vernünftige Entschädigungs äh regelung äh dafür und äh und sowas gibt es, also wenn
zum Beispiel so im amerikanischen Patentrecht wird halt
auch draufgeguckt bei bei jeder Patenterteilung ist das Patent vielleicht irgendwie äh von Relevanz für die nationale Sicherheit,
Und wenn dem so ist, dann äh kann halt äh beschlossen werden, dass dein Patent,
nicht veröffentlicht wird, sondern geheim gehalten wird und du wirst dann dafür aber als Erfinder entschädigt. Dafür, dass dein Patent äh dann geheim bleiben muss.
So. Mhm.
Also wenn's äh wenn's irgendwie um nationale Sicherheit geht äh kann sich der Staat sogar jedes Patent.
Exklusiv sichern sogar. Äh.
Na gut, ich denke, dabei können wir es jetzt erstmal äh belassen. Wir freuen uns auf unser, auf euer weiteres äh Feedback zu dem Thema.
Lass uns doch vielleicht mal auf die Zahlen schauen.
Okay.
So spannend sind sie wahrscheinlich nicht, aber äh.
Immer schon getan. Grundsätzlich blicken wir auf fallende Werte, so wird es ähm.
Nun wird es ähm.
Überall kommentiert und man freut sich natürlich. Ich habe einen Blick drauf geworfen und mal so ein bisschen die Kurve äh im Vergleich gezogen und wurden auch nochmal äh getwittert, dass,
den Stand, den wir da jetzt äh,
haben den den den hatten wir auch schon mal so, den hatten wir nämlich äh Ende Januar schon mal.
Auch so mit einer ähnlichen nach unten, bis es dann halt alles im Februar in diesen Lockerungsdiskussionen äh komplett sich umgedreht hat. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt.
Ein Vierteljahr, eigentlich komplett äh verloren durch die dritte Welle.
Weil wir halt einfach dann den letzten Lockdown verfrüht
gebrochen äh äh haben und äh eine dritte Welle äh zugelassen haben. Also wir hätten damit, wir hätten schon längst durch sein können, wie im letzten Jahr, mit dem ganzen und es hätte schon alles längst auf sein und äh ja
oder viel mehr längst auf sein äh.
Zumindest können wir portugiesische Verhältnisse könnten wir haben.
Ja, ja. Ähm.
Und stattdessen müssen wir jetzt weiter bisschen fürchten und bangen, dass sich das Ganze nochmal äh äh wiederholt, weil wir sind jetzt so nach wie, also wir sind jetzt noch längst nicht da, äh wo wir nach der,
zweiten Welle äh waren, also.
Den den Tiefpunkt äh der zweiten Welle, der war so Mitte Februar ungefähr und seitdem dann ging's halt langsam hoch und dann ging's,
Mitte März äh ging's dann halt richtig ab äh so bis äh Jahr eigentlich jetzt bis Anfang Mai, so eigentlich fallen die Zahlen erst seit den also zwei Wochen haben wir jetzt erst fallende Zahlen,
und.
Wir brauchen äh wahrscheinlich nochmal ja zwei nochmal zwei Wochen ähm.
So um äh tiefer runter zu kommen, wenn das so weitergeht ähm als wir in der,
als wir im im Februar schon waren, dann also so da waren wir schon mal.
Und ähm ja, aber vielleicht konkret ähm mal jetzt, weil wir haben noch keine einzige Zahl genannt,
obwohl wir über Zahlen reden, also die Inzidenz äh also die offizielle sieben Tage Inzidenz nach Maildatum liegt
bei sechsundneunzig Komma fünf, aber nach Publikationsdatum, also die einfach die Fälle genommen, die in den letzten sieben Tagen veröffentlicht wurden, sind's noch hundertzwei Komma drei
nach Publikationsdatum und.
Sagen wir mal hundert.
Jahrhundert, also round about hundert äh so
und ja, RRT ist auch nochmal ganz leicht auf null Komma acht sechs äh gesunken jetzt äh bundesweit und die Todesfälle sind auf tausendvierhundertsechsunddreißig.
In den letzten sieben Tagen zurückgegangen. Und auch nach Altersgruppen.
Sieht die sieben Tage Inzidenz ja,
unspektakulär aus äh nach wie vor noch die
Nummer fünf bis Vierzehnjährigen und die Fünfzehn bis Vierunddreißigjährigen sind noch führend in den Inzidenzen, also die, ich sage mal, Schüler mit hundertfünfundfünfzig und
die Jungen äh Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen bei hundertdreiundvierzig,
ja erfreulich ist aber auch, dass die Inzidenzen so in den älteren Altersgruppen auch weiter nach unten.
Gehen ähm zwo achtundfünfzig jetzt für die Sechzig- bis Neunundsiebzigjährigen und vierzig,
für achtzig Plus. Also das
ja, sieht schon mal gut aus, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwie einer den anderen unbedingt äh äh überholt hätte, sondern die bewegen sich alle äh weitgehend
im Gleichtakt sag ich mal.
Für die achtzig Plus, um das mal in äh Vergleich zu setzen, das war so das, was wir äh Ende Oktober hatten.
Als es so als als ich Deutschland aufgemacht hat in die zweite Welle zu starten. Und äh ja, das da ist also auch noch viel zu erreichen nach unten.
Ja, ja. Also äh und äh wie gesagt, ich meine tausendvierhundertsechsunddreißig Tote in sieben Tagen, das ist äh immer noch eine Menge.
Dass es immer noch zu viel.
Weißt du, in äh kannst du sagen, in welchen Altersgruppen die äh sozusagen am meisten gestorben.
Ja, RR achtzig Plus nach wie vor. Also es ist immer noch äh also in den Sterblichkeiten hat sich jetzt nicht so viel geändert. Ich meine, äh es sind meistens zwischen sagen siebzig.
Sechzig bis siebzig Prozent äh ungefähr ist achtzig Plus und äh die der restlichen
ja zwanzig bis dreißig Prozent ungefähr verteilen sich auf die anderen Altersgruppen aber wiederum davon so achtzig, neunzig Prozent äh,
in der Altersgruppe sechzig bis äh neunundsiebzig.
Drunter dann noch, ich meine für rund fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig ist auch noch äh signifikant, aber eben deutlich, deutlich weniger.
Ähm und auch wenn man sich
die pseudo Werte anguckt in den Altersgruppen, äh also wenn man jetzt einfach R-Wert auf Basis äh der Inzidenzen nach Altersgruppe berechnet, dann äh liegen die auch
alle nahe beieinander, zwischen null Komma acht vier und null Komma acht neun. Also mit anderen Worten ähm die.
Derzeit geht es in allen Altersgruppen relativ gleichmäßig zurück. Äh die Zahlen. Das ist ein seltener Zustand.
Meistens prescht irgendwie eine Altersgruppe vor oder oder aus, aber im Moment äh ist das nicht der Fall.
Und genauso auch äh bei den Inzidenzen bei den äh nach Bundesländern.
Auch unspektakulär so in weiter Sachsen und Thüringen äh führend und Schleswig-Holstein mit deutlich unterdurchschnittlicher Inzidenz. Die sind jetzt bei zweiundvierzig.
Und ansonsten der Rest bewegt sich so alles äh in einem verteilt sich im Mittelfeld.
Und.
Ja und wie du schon richtig sagtest, ich mache ja immer auch gerne so äh den den Jahresvergleich, so die Kurve vom letzten Jahr.
Ähm zeitlich mit der Kurve von diesem Jahr übereinander gelegt und.
Selbst wenn man jetzt die Kurve vom letzten Jahr wie ein höherer Inzidenz.
Ähm verdoppelt, dann sind wir immer noch nicht wieder beim auf dem Peak der ersten Welle. So ähm.
Das ist echt krass.
Es ist einfach die ganze Zeit immer nur schlechter geworden eigentlich, nachdem es einmal besser geworden ist. Was sagt dir das jetzt äh über unsere positiven Rate? Die müsste ja dann eigentlich auch gefallen sein.
Ja, ist sie auch. Ähm so ähm auf zehn Komma drei Prozent leicht gefallen.
Und äh ja, da waren wir eben auch schon mal Anfang des Jahres und vor Weihnachten auch äh bei dieser Rathaus passt also auch ganz gut.
Auch hier immer noch höhere positiven Quote als äh bei der ersten Welle. Und,
wir nähern uns sozusagen langsam dem dem schlimmsten Peak. Also daran kann man's wirklich vielleicht ganz gut sehen. Ich würde fast mal sagen, nächste Woche sind wir
wenn's so weiter geht. Nächste Woche sind wir an dem Punkt, an dem wir in der ersten, wo es in der ersten Welle am Schlimmsten war.
Absurdistan.
Nur dass der Punkt eben ähm zeitlich ja in der ersten Welle äh wann war genau der der Peak.
Von der ersten Welle. Ich gucke.
Nach positiven Quote KW vierzehn.
Ja, also Anfang April, also sechs zu sechser siebter.
Achter April rum. Also wir sind jetzt sozusagen,
hängen jetzt ja mehr als einen Monat, also fünf, sechs Wochen sozusagen äh hinken wir jetzt hinterher in diesem Jahr.
Mindestens. Und wir wissen ja noch nicht, ob's jetzt auch tatsächlich noch so weitergeht oder ob.
Nicht jetzt wir wieder nochmal durch die Lockerungen äh wieder eine deutliche Bremse kriegen oder vielleicht sogar nochmal eine Umkehr. Ich hoffe ja nicht.
Aber äh ich glaube auch nicht, dass das folgenlos bleiben wird. Also in den USA zum Beispiel habe ich äh gesehen, äh gab's jetzt sogar einen leichten Aufwärtstrend wieder aktuell äh in den, in den Zahlen, meine ich.
Bei den Infektionen. Habe ich mir jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, äh nicht angeschaut. Aber kann schon.
Ja, also ach so und die, ja und die Zahl der Tests ist äh leicht.
Oder ja es ist zurückgegangen um fast zehn Prozent auf eins Komma zwei zwei Millionen jetzt.
Ja und natürlich ist die da ich das jetzt die positiven Quote gesunken ist, um.
Acht Prozent ähm so muss natürlich.
Zahl der positiven Tests stärker gesunken sein, als die Zahl der Tests und das ist sie auch, also ja, siebzehn Prozent oder sechzehn Komma sieben Prozent weniger positive Tests und
nur neun Komma vier vier Prozent weniger Tests. Ja ähm ich glaube.
Das war's jetzt zu den Infektions äh Zahlen und ich übergebe jetzt an den unseren Experten im Team für Impfzahlen, Herrn Prittloff.
Ja, danke, Herr Meier. Das mache ich doch gerne. Ja, also ähm.
Ganz gut aus. Also es ist äh wirklich eine extrem äh aktive Woche und diese Woche haben wir äh die höchsten.
In den höchsten Impfzahlen überhaupt bisher erreicht.
Betrachte ja immer alles im Sieben-Tage-Schnitt, weil die Tage da eher so extrem auseinander sind durch Wochenende und auch äh Montag ist zum Beispiel selten äh viel los, also das größte Impfgeschehen spielt sich eigentlich immer so Mittwoch
ähm Mittwoch bis Freitag ab oder manchmal auch von von Dienstag bis äh Donnerstag, also so ein Dreitagesblock, der dominiert in der Regel.
Diese Woche äh hatten wir auch noch einen Feiertag aufn Donnerstag. Das hat sich natürlich dann extrem auch in den Zahlen wiedergespiegelt.
Wir hatten jetzt vorgestern wieder im Schnitt so knapp fünfhundertachtzigtausend Erst
Impfungen pro Tag im sieben Tagesschnitt äh erreicht. Da waren wir auch schon mal
Ende April, am dreißigsten vierten, dann gab's so 'n kleinen kleinen Knick, aber nicht nennenswert, also wir befinden uns eigentlich immer noch in dieser vierten Phase,
wo eben die Impfzahlen sich so zwischen fünfhundert äh und fünfhundertfünfzig, fünfhundertachtzigtausend äh bewegen
jetzt durch den Feiertag gestern und weil der Donnerstag ja normalerweise eigentlich immer ein sehr äh imfreudiger Tag ist.
Gehen die Durchschnittszahlen jetzt äh mal kurz runter, äh aber immer noch auf über fünfhunderttausend, also das ähm wird sich dann auch in den nächsten Tagen wieder schnell ausgleichen,
die,
Zahl der Zweitimpfung steigt allerdings jetzt kräftig an, sodass eben so die absolute Zahl von Erstimpfungen in den nächsten Wochen für mich so ein bisschen fraglich ist, wie gut das mit den neuen Lieferungen.
Dann zusammenpassen wird, da gibt's dann erst nächsten Montag wieder ein Update, äh um zu schauen, ob das auch alles so gekommen ist, wie es angekündigt wurde,
Ähm ich gehe davon aus, dass wir so in den nächsten Wochen so ein Battle haben werden. Also das einfach der Anzahl Anzahl von Zweitimpfungen ähm nochmal deutlich steigen wird und
So oder so, also wir haben äh einen Tag gehabt, wo eins Komma drei Millionen Dosen verimpft wurden. Das zeigt, dass die Kapazität, die das Land ähm
hat im Prinzip ausreicht, wenn genug Lieferungen da sind.
Es waren auch noch alle Impfstoffe ganz gut vertreten. Ähm also auch äh ist nochmal was reingekommen und das ähm,
Unten rufen zum Trotz, wird es auch abgenommen. Man muss da halt nur Leute dafür äh finden. Mittlerweile werden halt recht.
Viele Beschränkungen aufgehoben. Also in Berlin war's zum Beispiel so, dass vor ein, zwei Wochen hier die ganzen Universitäten mit reingenommen wurden.
Das waren dann alle Mitarbeiter, also alle Mitarbeiter der Universität, egal wo die arbeiten.
Plus auch so studentische Hilfskräfte.
Das zählte auch mit dazu, die waren dann auf einmal in in Prio drei und hatten dann, ja, natürlich auch alle versucht, sich irgendwie Termine zu klicken, die dann teilweise auch so Mitte, Ende Juni lagen.
So
Hilft das jetzt unbedingt und jetzt ist es sogar so, dass alle Priorisierung aufgehoben wird ab nächsten Montag, das gilt nicht nur in Berlin, das gilt meistens auch in Bayern und Baden-Württemberg und ich denke mal, wir werden das in den nächsten Wochen auch in den anderen Bundesländern sehen.
Für Astra oder generell?
Nick, für alle Impfstoffe überhaupt generell. Also es ist so für sich, wer kann.
Das ist einfach freies freier Wettlauf, äh um um Termine, um einfach alles irgendwie so auszunutzen, wie es irgendwie geht. Ich habe allerdings so den Eindruck,
dass.
Es schon auch noch Gründe gegeben hätte für eine Priorisierung. So, ich habe nur so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Die Politik überhaupt genug Zahlen, belastbare Zahlen hat, um einzuschätzen, wie weit die einzelnen Prio-Gruppen eigentlich wirklich durchgeimpft worden sind.
In den Meldungen wird ja nur zwischen Ü sechzig unter sechzig bei den Ärzten unterschieden. Mehr wird da ja gar nicht gemeldet.
Was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht verstehe, warum man nicht mit warum man nicht jede Impfung einzeln melden kann und zumindest sagen kann, Alter, fertig, ich meine.
Ja meinetwegen, aber irgendwo äh,
Irgendwo kann man's auch einfach total übertreiben. Ich meine, was was will man an der Stelle da noch groß äh schützen, wenn da keine Namen dabei sind? Es geht doch nur dadrum zu sagen, welches Alter ist geimpft worden, damit man mal ein Gefühl dafür bekommt
wie gut die einzelnen Altersgehorten jetzt abgedeckt sind oder nicht, weil ich glaube, diese diese Zahl gibt's immer noch nicht, ne. Also wie wie viel jetzt wirklich in den einzelnen Altersgeraten weggehen.
Und wir können, ich meine, anhand der Sterbezahlen können wir aber definitiv auch sagen,
vor drei Wochen äh noch äh ja in,
den Altersgruppen achtzig plus äh äh noch definitiv nicht genug Leute äh immun waren, ja.
So, sonst wären, sonst also äh die tausend äh ja, fünfhundert.
Sechsunddreißig Leute, die in den letzten sieben Tagen gestorben sind, hatten definitiv keinen Impfschutz. So und,
ähm ja und ob sich das in den letzten drei Wochen äh jetzt äh sagen, komplett verändert hat. Also bei den achtzig plus ist sicherlich,
sollten wir sicherlich jetzt irgendwo bei achtzig, neunzig Prozent angekommen sein, aber ich glaube, bei schon bei sechzig bis neunundsiebzig ähm würde mich wundern, wenn wir da über fünfzig Prozent äh wären gerade.
Also mehr Daten werden hier sicherlich hilfreich auch, wie viel Leute äh unter Umständen eine Impfung verweigert haben. Das mag's ja nun auch geben, dass Leute einfach sagen, na ja, hier ist ja nur ist ja nur eine kleine Grippe, das kommt ja in den besten Familien vor
dann kann man halt Glück haben oder auch nicht. Wissen wir alles nicht. So oder so, die Zahlen gehen zurück. Das heißt, äh mit jedem Tag Impfung wird's
und ja insgesamt sind wir ja auch bei recht äh beachtlichen äh äh warte mal, was ist die Zahl
ähm mhm fünfunddreißig Komma neun Prozent der Bevölkerung, die jetzt schon mindest eine Erstimpfung erhalten hat
Das ging recht schnell. Also wir haben das Drittel am Dienstag überschritten gehabt und seitdem schon äh sehr gut vorangekommen.
Wie viele haben jetzt eine Erst äh Impfung sagst du?
Fünfunddreißig Komma neun Prozent Stand heute.
Das sind in Millionen äh.
Das sind ähm neunundzwanzig Komma acht fünf Millionen.
Okay, neunundzwanzig Komma acht fünf Millionen. Gut, nur so zum Vergleich. Also wir haben in der Altersgruppe achtzig Plus, haben wir in Deutschland so fünf Komma sieben Millionen.
In der Altersgruppe sechzig bis neunundsiebzig haben wir achtzehn Millionen.
Also das macht zusammen sagen diese beiden Altersgruppen äh würden dann schon zweiundzwanzigeinhalb Millionen äh ausmachen, wenn man die komplett durch.
Geimpft hätte.
Siebzig plus ist das jetzt quasi. Ist sechzig.
Ja, sechzig, genau, sechzig bis neunundsiebzig sind sechzig plus, sechzig plu.
Genau sechzig plus äh wären halt dann ja dreiundzwanzig Millionen. Und weil wir aber wissen, äh dass äh ja teilweise,
die Hälfte der Impfstoffe äh nicht nach Altersindikation, sondern nach beruflicher Indikation vergeben wurde.
Also am Anfang zumindest, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt immer noch äh so eine große Rolle spielt, die berufliche Indikation.
Mittlerweile ja ist.
Du hast jetzt sehr viel ähm Vorerkrankungen, ne, die hier mit reinkamen, alles Mögliche.
Ja, das äh also.
Auf jeden Fall auch und ich meine die größte Altersgruppe hier, also es waren die fünfunddreißig bis bis neunundfünfzig äh in den RKI-Standard-Altersgruppen, das sind halt siebenundzwanzigeinhalb Millionen.
Achtzehn Millionen fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährige und äh ja zehn Millionen ungefähr Kinder äh bis vierzehn Jahre. Das ist so.
Sind so die Zahlen in den Altersgruppen.
Ja, also rein in Zahlen, nach, rein theoretisch könnte man äh hätte man aller äh alten Menschen impfen können, ob sich wirklich auch alle haben impfen lassen wollen, wissen wir nicht, das kann man aus diesen Zahlen auch nicht rauslesen, ne.
Ganz interessant ist auch noch so der Unterschied in den Bundesländern, also mittlerweile klafft's da auch schon ganz ordentlich auseinander,
Also während du so bei den Erstimpfungen.
Spitzenreiter Saarland mit vierzig äh Komma vier Prozent und äh Sachsen mit einunddreißig Komma eins Prozent. Das ist schon äh eine erheblicher Unterschied.
Ähm bei den Zweitimpfungen wiederum sieht's anders aus und daraus lässt sich halt ableiten, dass die Länder äh offensichtlich andere Prioritäten haben.
Weil da ist irgendwie äh Sachsen wiederum relativ weit vorne und das Saarland äh eher so im Mittelfeld. Also
kann man nicht jetzt sagen, dass hier irgendeiner eine bessere äh Strategie hätte als die anderen. Das hat ja auch was mit den Lieferungen zu tun, sondern einfach unterschiedliche Strategien.
Es wurde auch mitbekommen, mal gucken, es gab wohl auch Regionen, wo man äh die Bevölkerung dann auch komplett äh durchgeimpft hat.
Besonders betroffen waren. Genau, das sind die die Grenzregionen, die sogenannten, da gehört das Saarland auch dazu, das ist äh definitiv ein Teil, da gehört aber auch Sachsen dazu.
Ja, also äh gerade da diese ähm Regionen äh Richtung Tschechien, ja, das Osterzgebirge.
Um das mal richtig ausgesprochen äh zu haben.
Osterzgebirge.
Genau, das Ostergebirge. Ähm Bayern, äh Tischenreuth hatten wir ja auch schon hier äh besprochen, diese äh,
Interessanterweise gab's wohl auch äh Lieferungen nach Sachsen-Anhalt, wobei mir nicht ganz klar ist, mit was Sachsen-Anhalt eine Grenze haben sollte, außer Sachsen jetzt, aber und Thüringen.
Details, ne. Insgesamt kann man sagen, geht ganz gut voran und viel wird jetzt von den Lieferungen der nächsten Wochen abhängen, denn da gibt's halt nur so,
zusagen ähm und vor allem gibt's sehr.
Schwierig zu deutende PDF äh Dokumente. Ich habe mich da schon ein paar Mal vertan, deswegen mache ich jetzt hier auch grad keine äh Voraussage insgesamt,
Hatten wir aber jetzt relativ lieferstarke Monate oder Wochen zumindest die letzten äh zwei Wochen
sehr lieferstark und jetzt müssen wir gucken wie das weitergeht. Ähm ich denke, es wird eine kleine Delle geben bei den Erstimpfungen für die nächsten drei Wochen und das Ganze äh oder die nächsten
nächsten zwei Wochen und dann.
Kann sich das im Juni alles wieder ausgleichen mit relativ äh starken Lieferungen von von Biotech. Da geht's dann äh wieder nach vorne.
Wenn ich da deine Grafiken so richtig interpretiere, wäre es durchaus möglich,
je nachdem, äh dass es einen kurzen Zeitraum gibt, wo äh es mehr Zweitimpfungen als Erstimpfungen geben könnte pro Tag. Sehe ich das richtig?
Kann sein, meine also muss sagen, meine Vorhersage ist, so ist extrem Pi mal Daumen. Ich habe jetzt da nicht äh weil da hätte man jetzt ein bisschen äh intensiver berechnen müssen. Es gibt ein paar äh Webseiten, die das noch etwas genauer
aufschlüsseln und alle möglichen Aspekte äh da mit reinmachen und auch noch äh Annahmen darüber machen, was ist, wenn jetzt Asra auf
Biotech übergeht und so weiter. Äh da sind ja noch viele Fragen offen.
Da mir das zu viel Klein klein war und mir es nur darum ging, ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie ist es denn bisher gelaufen.
Also was was haben wir real,
kann ich das nicht wirklich beantworten, aber ist durchaus. Also die, die der Anteil der Zweitimpfung schießt auf jeden Fall stark nach oben. Ob's äh so eine fifty fifty Geschichte wird
In Niedersachsen sind jetzt zum Beispiel erst Impfung war für zwei Wochen ausgesetzt worden.
Nur zweigeimpft, genau. Wobei man auch sagen muss, das ist dann für die Impfzentren auch dahingehend gut, als dass sie natürlich deutlich weniger Paper Work haben, weil natürlich die zweit äh Geimpften, die kommen einfach nur äh wieder,
ist dann schon alles klar. Die kommen rein, setzen sich hin, Pieks und zack und wieder raus. Ähm die kriegen also sehr viel mehr Zweitimpfung durchgesetzt. Das heißt, das.
Kann dann auch bedeuten, dass dass der dass der Durchsatz sich steigert, aber alles hängt letzten Endes an Lieferungen, weil wenn wir in der Lage sind, eins Komma drei Millionen Impfungen pro Tag zu verteilen, ja? Das hätte ich auch gerne jeden Tag,
nur so Schnitt von einer Million werden wir, glaube ich, nicht erreichen. Aber wir sind jetzt mit den fünfhunderttausend oder fünfhundertfünzigtausend in diesem Bereich, den wir uns befinden, glaube ich, erstmal ganz gut bedient. Und ich glaube, das wird auch noch ein, zwei Wochen halten. Also Erstimpfung meine ich jetzt, ne.
Ja, mehr kann man dazu zu diesem Zeitpunkt eigentlich nicht sagen.
Ähm also meine Schätzung.
Wäre ähm auch wenn sagen, wenn genug Impfstoff da wäre und äh auch äh die Inzentivierung für Ärzte ausreichend wäre, auch in ihrer Praxis zu impfen.
Könnten wir, ich sag mal.
Allein die Ärzte, also ohne Impfzentren könnte man wahrscheinlich zwischen zwei und vier Millionen Impfungen pro Tag äh durchführen äh so über die,
niedergelassenen Ärzte und mit Impfzentren ist äh das natürlich nach oben offen, also Impfzentren könnten, wenn man irgendwie sagen würde, wir.
Fahren das jetzt mit dem Zentrum massiv hoch äh genug Impfstoff da wäre, könnte man auch in zwei,
bis vier Wochen die gesamte Bevölkerung durchimpfen. Ich fände das ja eigentlich gut, wenn es äh wenn wir.
Sagen, so eine Infrastruktur hätten, die das zulässt, dass man die gesamte Bevölkerung in zwei Wochen durchimpft.
Oder eine Woche.
Also es geht. Das ist jetzt wäre jetzt nicht also wäre jetzt nicht völlig utopisch oder außerhalb des möglichen, würde auch nicht irrsinnig viel Geld kosten.
Ja, ist aber nur eine müßige Überlegung zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man einfach noch einen Impfstoffmangel hat an der Stelle, ne?
Na ja, nee, aber so grundsätzlich als gesellschaftliches Ziel, finde ich. Ähm sollte man mal darüber.
Nachdenken, also wenn ich politische Partei äh wäre, würde ich ja.
Zum Beispiel ja, vor allem oder fordern können, dass äh wir einfach unsere Pandemievorbereitung dahingehend verbessern, dass es halt.
Genügend, zum einen genügend Kapazitäten gibt, um ich sage mal innerhalb von vier Wochen, ausreichend Impfstoff für die gesamte Bevölkerung herzustellen und den innerhalb von einer Woche zu verimpfen.
Ja? Ist jetzt nix irgendwie ja, was im im Vergleich zu anderen Dingen jetzt äh besonders teuer oder.
Unerreichbar wäre. So, meiner Meinung nach und dann äh ja.
Müssten wir bei der nächsten Pandemie äh nicht wieder äh nicht wieder so rumeiern und die nächste Pandemie wird kommen, ja. Da ist äh.
Dabei ist die Maus keinen Faden ab, ja? Also.
Nächste Pandemie wird einfach mit dem RNA-Drucker weggetackert.
Aber dazu ich meine, das ist genau der Punkt, äh was ich ja nur meine ist, ähm.
Und solche RNA-Drucker ähm sind jetzt nicht unbedingt ideal, um jetzt einmal so was in der Pandemie große Mengen von demselben Impfstoff äh,
zu herzustellen, sondern da willst du halt schon einfach auch Anlagen haben, die Kapazität können.
Idealerweise lässt man sich irgendwas einfallen, dass dafür sorgt, dass wir halt ähm ja ähm für alle möglichen Zwecke RNA.
Ähm ja, noch nicht mal Impfstoff, sondern ich sage mal, ähm RNA Einschleus äh.
Ähm Produktion ähm ja, würde man sagen, ähm.
Sag es, du willst alle verchippen.
Ne, wie ich, ich überlege, ich ich überlege gerade, was denn äh so einen so einen.
Richtiger oder oder passender Begriff ist für ähm,
Medikamente oder für, ich sage mal, RNA eingepackt in Lipide. Das müssen ja nicht nur Impfstoffe sein, sondern äh das ist ja generisches Ding. Das ist ja irgendwie äh ich sage mal.
Herstellung von,
RNA basierten Zellprogrammierstoffen. So äh ja, äh dass wir da einfach in der Lage sind äh,
von im Prinzip die gesamte Bevölkerung mit zu versorgen. So, dass wir diese Kapazitäten haben.
Wir hatten ja schon in unserer Folge mit dem schönen Namen der Impfstoff ist es eine App, äh uns ausführlich darüber unterhalten, wie sehr das vergleichbar ist, diese ganze RNA Geschichte mit äh mit Apps und Software. Und tatsächlich,
ein ganz äh angemessene Methode darüber nachzudenken, denn im Wesentlichen funktioniert es tatsächlich so. Wir reden hier wirklich von einer Programmierung des Körpers,
und wir sind in der Lage im Prinzip.
Weiß nicht, ob man jetzt beliebige Stoffe herstellen kann, aber ich würde mal sagen, schon die notwendige Bandbreite, äh ja, also was auch immer der Körper selber tun kann, kann man ihm jetzt auch sagen.
Also ich glaube, du kannst auch äh mein ähm ja also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, äh wo da wirklich die Grenzen äh liegen,
dessen, wozu man äh den Körper bringen kann. Man gut.
Ähm also alles, was man mit Protein irgendwie machen kann und ich wüsste nicht, dass es irgendwie Dinge gibt, die man mit Proteinen nicht äh machen könnte äh äh so in bestimmten Temperaturbereichen. Also,
wir jetzt sagen ähm was also Proteine, ich meine es sind halt.
Auch universelle Maschinen äh äh letztlich ähm die äh von denen wir reden, die ja.
Einfach jeden Quatsch machen könnt im Körper, weil das ist genau das, was sie tun.
Also es ist für mich auch so ein bisschen so eine so eine grundlegende Erkenntnis dieser ganzen Zeit gewesen, einfach so zu verstehen, dass so Proteine so biologische Universalmaschinen sind
die äh allen möglichen Scheiß machen können, ja? Die trennen Dinge auf, die bekämpfen irgendwas, die dringen ein und
produzieren und machen und tun und es äh äh es ist wirklich erstaunlich, welche Komplexität diese Biologie entwickelt hat ähm.
Um dann so viel selbstzerstörerische Menschen damit vor, rauszubringen, irgendwie zu produzieren. Bisschen dahinten losgegangen. Na gut. Immerhin haben wir ein paar dabei, die verstanden haben, wie das funktioniert. Ist ja auch schon mal was.
Gut, so viel äh zur Impfkampagne. Ähm.
Und unserer Begeisterung über RNA Technologie. Vielleicht noch so ein paar kleinere Meldungen von der Front. Ähm die WHO hat wohl auch so eine.
Notfallzulassung äh erteilt für Sinopfarm, für diesen chinesischen Impfstoff, wobei die äh Chinesen ja wohl auch selber eingestanden haben, dass sie so mit ihren Impfstoffen nicht so in so einem,
super Effizienzbereich gelandet sind, ne? Das äh trotz trotzdem gibt's Wirkung, so ist es jetzt äh.
Nicht und ähm damit könnte halt diese Impfstoffe äh auch dieser Kovacs in die Initiative zugute kommen.
Dann hat die WHO ähm die neue Variante,
eins, sechs, eins, sieben, aus Indien, auch äh jetzt wohl als Variant of Konzern eingestuft.
Denn das hat sich wohl gezeigt, dass sie auch wie B eins eins sieben korrigiere mich, wenn ich das falsch verstanden habe, wie B eins eins sieben ganz gute Transmissibilitär äh hat. Sie setzt sich nämlich gerade in,
Großbritannien auch relativ schnell durch und das ist ja so ein bisschen der der Ort, wo B eins, eins, sieben, eins, sein Wesen, äh sein Unwesen getrieben hat,
Offensichtlich kann diese indische Variante da noch einen drauflegen und ist zumindest jetzt bei diesen niedrigen Inzidenzen in der Lage, ähm sich da äh weiter zu verbreiten.
B eins eins sieben noch kann.
Interessant. Ja, das war ja erstmal nicht so, aber hm. Ja, wenn man beobachten.
Ja, ansonsten gibt's aber da relativ wenig zu befürchten, glaube ich, also die Impfstoffe wirken auch gegen die indische Variante genauso. Ähm das hat man ja hier auch schon besprochen, von daher ist das für mich derzeit eigentlich eher eine Randnotiz.
Auch äh eine Randnotiz, wenn gleich auch eine ganz vielversprechender ist, dass bayontech Pfizer.
Seinen Impfstoff jetzt in den USA, auch für zwölf bis Fünfzehnjährige im Rahmen einer Notfallzulassung zugelassen bekommen hat, die USA geht da weiter relativ hemdsärmlig äh ran an diese Geschichte
und ähm nächste Woche soll das wohl schon losgehen, dass Kinder sich da in Apotheken oder wo auch immer impfen lassen können.
Der der Hintergrund.
Wie ich auch aus der letzten äh Clubhaus-Runde äh gelernt habe, was ich ganz interessant fand, war hm.
Dass ähm ja bei den, dass die Zwölf- bis Fünfzehnjährigen im Prinzip,
wie Erwachsene äh behandelt werden. Äh also sprich äh die gleiche Impfung,
bekommen, während man für jüngere Kinder, speziell natürlich für die Absechsjährigen, ähm
muss man dann äh äh sechs Monate so. Äh Dosierungsstudien äh durchführen, die auch laufen, weil man dort halt gucken muss, äh so äh ja in der Regel
reichen da dann eben auch kleinere Dosen aus, aber man möchte halt wissen, ähm so wie groß die Dosen sind und,
ansonsten äh ist aber kann man in der Regel davon ausgehen, dass Impfstoffe, die für Erwachsene geeignet sind, äh bei Kindern nichts Schlimmes tun.
So, aber ähm man braucht natürlich trotzdem die Studienzeit trotzdem äh genau wissen
Und äh insofern ist das jetzt wir sagen, dass jetzt die Zwölfjährigen äh oder ab zwölf äh geimpft,
ist jetzt äh wahrscheinlich nicht äh Reckless äh verantwortungslos oder so, sondern im Rahmen dessen, was man, glaube ich, rechtfertigen kann und,
Ähm ja.
So oder so wird das für uns natürlich dann Zahlen liefern. Das ist ja klar, weil sollte es Probleme geben in diesem Altersbereich mit, dann wird man das wahrscheinlich dann auch bald feststellen können.
Israel impft doch auch schon seit längerem äh jüngere.
Bist du dir da sicher, Israel, dass die Studie aus Israel kommt dazu? Das war mir klar.
Okay.
Aber dass das in Israel auch stattfindet, das.
Auch äh äh relativ frisch äh sehe ich gerade vom vierten, fünften äh also sie warten auch auf die amerikanische Zulassung wohl.
Genau, die ist jetzt quasi erfolgt.
Das heißt, in Israel wird also auch äh sofort loslegen mit zwölf bis Fünfzehnjährigen. Und erwarten, dass Kinder unter zwölf noch im Herbst geimpft werden können.
Genau und in Europa, also in Deutschland habe ich davon gehört, dass Herbst eher die Erwartung ist für diese zwölf bis äh Fünfzehnjährigen. Mich jetzt ein bisschen gewundert hat, dieser Zeitraum.
Ist aber jetzt auch gerade ein bisschen äh wenig mit mit Quellen unterfüttert. Das ist so ein bisschen an mir vorbei geflogen. Ich habe mir das gerade nicht so gemerkt, das werden wir sehen. Ich glaube, der Druck wird schon noch steigen. Jetzt gerade zum Ende der Sommerferien hin vielleicht auch schon einen großen Teil,
Kinder geimpft zu bekommen. Fände ich auf jeden Fall gut, weil wenn jetzt wirklich im Juni, Juli, ähm wir in diesem Punkt kommen, dass wir mehr Impfstoffe haben,
Leute, die dafür Schlange stehen, dann sage ich nur, Frauen und Kinder zuerst, so.
Also ich gehe auch stark davon aus, dass wir dann auch.
Früher anfangen werden, auch Zwölfjährige mit einzubeziehen. Äh aber wir warten natürlich mal, äh gucken mal, was in Israel und den USA passiert.
Dass dazu Problemen führt.
Ja, dann gibt's äh weitere sich verdichtende Informationen, dass dieser digitale Impfpass ausgerollt werden sollte. Äh ich hatte da ja hier auch schon mal was dazu gesagt und so ein bisschen meine Zweifel angemeldet, dass das,
schnell vonstatten gehen kann, beziehungsweise mir ein bisschen unklar war, wie denn die bisher erfolgten Impfungen denn so zurückgemeldet werden sollen,
zeichnet sich ab, dass man wohl davon ausgeht, dass man das in irgendeiner Form per Post äh realisieren kann, sprich,
Leute bekommen dann so einen QR-Code äh auf Papier zugeschickt auf Basis der Daten in den Impfzentren. Das deckt zumindest die Leute aus den Impfzentren ab. Das ist schon mal ganz gut. Deckt aber eben noch nicht die äh Ärzte ab,
wo man wohl so ein bisschen die Hoffnung hat, dass man da die Technik äh schnell genug,
hinbekommt, um einen entsprechenden QR-Code für diesen Nachweis in den Arztpraxen selber zu produzieren. Da halte ich mal meine Luft nicht an,
da habe ich äh äh doch starke Zweifel, dass das alles so schnell gelingen wird, aber das wird sich zeigen, vielleicht liege ich ja auch falsch.
Oder so,
ist wohl die Zahl der gefälschten Impfpässe steigt wohl, also das Angebot ist auf jeden Fall da qualifizieren kann ich das jetzt hier nicht aus diesen Berichten, aber,
Gibt viele Berichte von Stempel Onlineshops, die so dubiose Bestellung für äh Adressstempel von Ärzten bekommen und so weiter, die dann aber ein ganz anderer Adressen gesendet werden sollen und all diese Geschichten
ich sage mal so, eine Menge,
Anfangsverdacht Material für die Polizei hier entsprechenden Hobbyfälschern auf die Spur zu kommen. Das wird man nochmal sehen.
Ja und wie letzten Endes das dann insgesamt laufen soll mit diesem Nachweis, also ich bin da noch,
Äh noch verhalten skeptisch. In den nächsten Wochen sollen ja dann angeblich neue Nachrichten kommen, sprich eine App releast werden oder mehrere sogar tatsächlich
auch die Fähigkeit wohl in die Corona-Warn-App diesen QR-Code einlesen zu können. Gut.
Da äh schauen wir einfach mal, was passiert nach wie vor ist es eben sehr unklar ob ob die Datenlage bei Immobilien Impfteams zum Beispiel überhaupt ausreicht, um das zu leisten.
Auch nur gehört, dass jetzt sozusagen mit den Datenschützern verhandelt äh wird äh.
Denn und ob und unter welchen Bedingungen und wie denn jetzt die Daten aus den Impfzentren
genutzt werden können, weil eben in sich beim letzten Mal, glaube ich, auch schon meinte, ist, ähm dass halt die Daten teilweise eben nicht also dass die Daten nicht dafür erhoben,
wurden äh so und das eine Weitergabe der Daten für diesen Zweck oder eine Verarbeitung der Nutzung der Daten für diesen Zweck nicht so ganz ohne ist. So und dass man deswegen aber versucht
schon im vornherein mit den Datenschützern äh sich von denen okay zu holen. Ja.
Ansonsten, ich weiß nicht, also für mich riecht diese äh,
riechen diese Meldungen über äh gefälschte Impfpässe, die riechen für mich irgendwie nach Propaganda.
Ehrlich gesagt, weil ähm so also Fakten äh sehe ich jetzt noch keine.
Immer nur Andeutungen, ja irgendwie im Internet, gibt's das irgendwie jetzt, aber wie viele davon sind denn jetzt tatsächlich im Umlauf?
Ja, wie viele Leute haben sich denn tatsächlich so ein Ding zugelegt oder oder sind mit gefälschten Pässen äh äh unterwegs, ja? Kann kein Mensch sagen,
Ob das jetzt irgendwie hundert oder eine Million Leute sind,
und ich glaube äh es bewegt sich eher in den hunderten wahrscheinlich, vielleicht in den Tausenden, aber in keiner Dimension glaube ich, wo das äh wirklich relevant wäre.
Ja, ist meine äh meine Sicht, weil ja also.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin da, ich bin da irgendwie, also bei mir triggert äh diese ganze Geschichte so Propaganda-Alarm. Ähm.
Propaganda Pro äh einer digitalen Lösung oder was.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Vorstellbar, aber.
Die Wahrheit liegt so irgendwo so dazwischen. Also es findet statt, es ist natürlich nicht gut, gerade was so Pandemie und Security äh betrifft. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich eh nicht so davon überzeugt, dass dieser ganze Überprüfungskram so funktionieren wird.
Nein, aber der bringt Jacke auch keine zusätzliche Sicherheit, weil die äh Dinger bleiben ja weiter gültig.
Ach so, du meinst der digitale Impfpass.
Digital.
Aber generell, ich meine, was ich meinte, ist das Belegen einer Impfung, dass das nicht nennenswert zu einer Sicherheit beitragen wird, einfach weil es einfach.
So breitbandig ignoriert werden wird. Ja, also es wird wenige Stellen geben, wo es wirklich so ein hop oder top Moment ist, ne, sagen wir mal eine,
Auslandsreise oder so, also irgendwas halbwegs äh hochkarätiges oder keine Ahnung, wenn sie mal wieder so ein G7-Gipfel treffen und so. Da werden sie wahrscheinlich auf sowas wirklich achten. Und sich das echt genau anschauen. Also wenn das so so ein bisschen hoch
unterwegs ist, dann dann schon,
Casual, ich mein da muss man sich doch nur anschauen, wie das hier irgendwie mit diesen ganzen anderen Apps äh so läuft. Das stört doch alles nur in so einem Laden oder.
Bin ja auch irgendwo mal so ein Starbucks äh äh reinmarschiert in Berlin, als ich mal wieder Ausgang hatte war ja so selten dieser Stadt in dem letzten Jahr, aber bin ich da irgendwie mal kurz rein, weil ich Hunger hatte.
Und da lag dann halt so neben der Kasse irgendwo so, ja hier irgendwie Luca-App, QR-Code, interessiert sich dafür. Weißt du,
Bedingungen für irgendwas. Es ist einfach liegt da so rum und Leute gehen rein, holen ihr einen Kaffee und gehen wieder raus. Äh,
So läuft das und so wird es auch mit diesen Impfnachweisen laufen.
Ja und es wird halt auch nur eine eine vorübergehende Geschichte sein. Also.
Man kann das eher, ich sage mal, äh also es hat vielleicht seine Rechtfertigung als ähm ja äh um um bestimmte Transaktionen oder Nachweise zu,
erleichtern oder vielleicht weniger Informationen preiszugeben und so, von daher äh würde ich das Ganze eher als, ja,
Angebot äh äh sehen, das eine oder andere vielleicht etwas einfacher äh zu zu machen, aber
ob das gelingt so also ob.
Das das muss sich noch noch zeigen und ich glaube auch, das wird das wird länger dauern. Also ich glaube, die ganze Sache wird länger dauern, als das Thema äh aktuell sein wird. Hoffe ich.
Das kann gut sein.
Ja, dann noch äh kurze Sache, die Corona-Warn-App kriegt am laufenden Meter neue Features. Demnächst soll sie wohl auch ein äh oder die hat jetzt wohl auch schon ein Feature zum schnellen Erfassen der Daten für einen Schnelltest bekommen.
Also mittlerweile kommen schon ganz pfiffige Sachen da rein. So nach dem Motto, jedes Mal, wenn ich zum Schnelltest renne, muss ich irgendwie Daten hinterlassen.
Und dann ist das sozusagen so eine Datenaustausch äh.
Maschine, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, läuft wahrscheinlich auch über äh QR-Codes, das heißt, man tippt halt irgendwie so die Daten ein, die man da eh abgeben muss, dann hält man einfach QR-Code hin. So, hier zack sind meine Daten, damit ähm die Turnaroundzeit da verbessert werden kann.
Ja und der Impfpass soll ja dann letzten Endes in der Corona-Warn-App auch angezeigt werden können.
Wird man sehen, aber ich find's gut. Ich find's generell gut, dass in diesem dass dieses Tool jetzt so ein bisschen entdeckt wird. Und dass dass man das so nutzt. Bisschen spät, aber äh besser als nichts.
Ja, ja. Aber wie gesagt, der der Hinweis auf äh äh Fälschungen, äh in dem Zusammenhang ist, den halte ich für irreführend, weil
dieser digitale Impfnachweis an der Situation genau null ändert.
Du kannst trotzdem mit deinem gefälschten gelben Dingen rumlaufen und dich ausweisen, ne.
Ähm so und dann ich weiß nicht, ob du's mitbekommen hast, aber es gibt ein ein äh ein Infektionsausbruch in Taiwan.
Oh mein Gott.
Es ist äh passiert, das Land ist im Krisenmodus, ja, also wirklich.
Die Insel der Glückseligkeit in dieser ganzen Krise mal von Neuseeland äh vielleicht noch abgesehen.
Ja, Alarmstufe zwei ist jetzt beschlossen worden. Man sieht richtig brennende Mülltonnen vor seinem geistigen Auge. Was ist passiert?
Es gab dreiundzwanzig neue lokale Fälle.
Dreiundzwanzig und äh man ist kurz vor Alarmstufe äh drei. Und dachte ich mir so, was, wie, was, was geht denn jetzt ab hier irgendwie Taiwan?
Doch immer so gut aufgepasst, wie kann euch das jetzt äh passieren, dass das Land jetzt bald im Untergang geweiht ist? Naja, stellt sich raus, die triggern einfach ihre Alarmstufen dann doch schon ein bisschen früher als wir.
Dreiundzwanzig neue lokale Fälle und,
Das eigentliche Problem dabei ist, dass die Contact Tracer bei nicht allen Fällen wussten, woher das kam.
Und daraufhin habe ich mir mal so deren Alarmsystem angeschaut, um mal zu gucken, was die eigentlich so für eine Einstufung haben. Und das ist wirklich sehr interessant. Also es gibt da vier.
Oder mindestens vier ich habe hier eine Grafik mit rechts, aber der ist schon rot, also ich glaube, das war's dann auch.
Die erste Phase ist sozusagen die Phase, in der man sich die ganze Zeit befindet. Also Stufe eins, die halt einfach sagt, ähm.
Tragt Masken im ÖPNV und an gut bevölkerten Plätzen.
Das reicht dann wahrscheinlich auch als Hinweis. Weiß ja, wie man das in Deutschland macht. Da sagt man, in der Bergendorfer Straße neunzehn bis siebenunddreißig und achtundvierzig bis äh neunundfünfzig eine Maske tragen, bitte.
So, das macht Deutschland auch irgendwie äh keiner nach. Auf große Events sollte verzichtet werden und öffentliche,
Orte und Firmen müssen äh einen DJ machen und äh Temperaturen nehmen und äh generell auf Abstand und Desinfektion.
Achten. Das war jetzt aber mal der Zustand, den sie die ganzen letzten Monate gehabt haben. Und der Alarmstufe zwei, die halt jetzt durch diesen Vorfall ausgelöst wurde, war.
Es gelten Geldstrafen bei Verstoß gegen Maskenpflicht.
Hatten wir, glaube ich, hier nie so richtig, ne? Veranstaltungen über fünfhundert draußen und und äh hundert Leuten in sind verboten. Öffentliche Events, äh Maskenpflicht für alle.
Und äh Läden können geschlossen werden, wenn sie äh bestimmte Crowd-Control-Mesurs nicht äh durchsetzen und bei Bedarf ähm werden auch noch alle Freizeitorte und öffentliche Orte geschlossen.
Das ist die Reaktion von Taiwan auf dreiundzwanzig Fälle, wo man nicht hundertprozentig weiß, woher die kommen. Ne, und so ist es auch definiert. Local Infection Cases, with un Identifal,
Originals. So und was halt jetzt gedroht hat, ist,
Phase drei. Die greift, wenn's äh man drei Cluster-Infektionen äh in einer Woche oder zehn bestätigte lokale Fälle innerhalb eines Tages ohne äh Informationen über die Herkunft hat,
Also auch das triggert relativ schnell. Dann heißt es draußen Masten überall, draußen immer tragen.
Treffen nur noch für zehn Personen äh draußen. Fünf Personen äh in und äh alle Läden sind zu. Medical und Government Service ist das Einzige, was da noch,
laufen darf,
Und äh wenn's äh erforderlich ist, machen sie auch noch komplette Communitys zu. Also sie würden halt auch noch Dörfer ähm oder Städte im Zeissfall halt auch komplett äh abriegeln mit keiner Reihen, keiner raus. So. Das wäre Phase drei.
Und wenn's dann halt richtig brennt, äh ist noch eine vierte Phase vorgesehen, die bei hundert Fällen pro Tag an zwei aufeinander liegenden Wochen,
greift,
oder wenn äh unklarer Herkunft bei Hälfte der bekannten Fälle ist und dann äh heißt es halt, alle bleiben drin, nur noch Supermarkt, Arzt äh Arbeit in eingeschränkten Maße,
so keine Events äh keine öffentlichen Facilitys, nix, keine Schule, Arbeit, alles dicht so. So macht das Taiwan.
Ist fast schon ein bisschen müßig, da überhaupt noch drauf hinzuweisen, weil ich glaube, es hat gar keiner mehr zu.
Ich höre nichts, ist so laut in Deutschland, dass man, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht mehr bereit ist, sich mit so etwas äh noch nennenswert zu beschäftigen.
Ja, aber das ist äh in im Prinzip ähm ja
so wie man es das machen muss in dem Moment wo man auch nur einen einzigen Kontakt
oder eine einzige Infektion äh nicht äh zurückführen äh äh kann äh hat man die Kontrolle verloren, ja.
Das ist äh sagen, das Ding, dann ist es nicht mehr unter Kontrolle und macht einfach.
Hinsicht hatten wir ja nie irgendwas unter.
Nee.
Das kann man, glaube ich, mal festhalten.
Wirklich, ja, wir hatten, ich meine, wir hatten im letzten Sommer halt das das Glück, dass wir tatsächlich äh ja, doch die Inzidenzen,
auf drei äh runtergebracht haben
und ähm ja, dann einfach äh mit mit Sommer und allem äh das Glück hatten, dass das erstmal unten geblieben,
Sogar wir haben sogar irgendwie den den Influx äh von Corona aus im Ausland äh sogar noch mit verkraftet äh sage ich mal.
Aber hm ja.
Im September ist es dann entglitten.
Aber Kontrolle hatten wir, hatten wir da nie äh richtig so.
Was was wirklich schade ist ja weil wir eine Chance hatten die Situation unter Kontrolle zu bringen mehrfach.
Und sie mehrfach nicht genutzt haben.
In Taiwan hat man es aber mittlerweile rausgefunden, das war wohl eine Flugzeug-Crew wiederum, die die äh Ursache war. Bin ich überraschend und ich glaube, auf Alarmstufe drei wird verzichtet und wahrscheinlich geht's auch bald wieder auf Alarmstufe eins zurück.
Ja, Pavel, dann kommen wir zu unserem Ausblick kommen.
Das ging aber heute schnell irgendwie gefühlt, ja? Ja. Ja, Ausblick.
Hatten wir äh teilweise schon, also hm.
Der kurzfristige Ausblick ist gut so, keine, es gibt im Moment keinerlei Anzeichen dafür,
dass sich das irgendwie drehen würde äh im Moment irgendwo, aber äh.
Ja, es äh bleibt halt jetzt sehr interessant,
wie, das wird, äh wenn jetzt geöffnet und gelockert wird. Ich glaube, wenn ich das so richtig gesehen habe, äh möchte man jetzt doch teilweise sehr umfassend öffnen,
ähm so, aber ja wir werden sehen.
Weiß nicht. Und also ich ich befürchte ja, dass äh wir äh,
da nochmal eine deutliche Verlangsamung oder vielleicht äh nochmal,
ja, einen einen kleinen Aufschwung äh kriegen, aber sicher Vorhersagen lässt sich es nicht, weil das hängt halt wirklich gerade davon ab, wie schnell was geöffnet wird.
Und ähm ja so des Weiteren mein Eindruck ist, dass äh.
Wahrscheinlich gerade ja der Haupteffekt durch Schulschließungen und Ausgangssperren äh jetzt erzielt,
wurde, dass das halt äh das das Hauptding ist und beides fällt ja demnächst weg.
Und ähm ja, also ich glaube ja, viele Schulen fangen wieder an und äh die Ausgangssperren dürften jetzt auch demnächst.
Wegfallen.
Das heißt, die ganzen Partyjugendlichen können sich dann wieder nachts treffen und sich gegenseitig anstecken und das dann in die Schule bringen und dort verbreiten.
Und ihre Eltern anstecken.
Ja, man kann eigentlich äh nur drauf trinken äh eben für sich, wer kann, also ihr müsst äh einfach schauen, dass ihr alle irgendwie äh eine Impfung bekommt.
Wurde ja schon eine Idee von mir aufgegriffen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast.
Bezog sich ja eigentlich auf die Corona-Warn-Eppich, hatte ja gesagt, wir warum baut ihr denn da keine Lotterie ein irgendwie, dann hätten die Leute mal einen Grund, sich diese App zu installieren, kostet ja irgendwie auch
quasi nix. In nur Aio haben sie das jetzt tatsächlich gemacht. Die wollen dann irgendwie fünf äh eine Millionen Dollar Lotterien irgendwie
für die Leute ausschreiben, die sich haben impfen lassen.
Mhm, ne?
Finde ich eigentlich.
Eine gute Idee. Ja, also sie machen das irgendwie es gibt, glaube ich, über einen Zeitraum von fünf Wochen, einmal die Woche irgendwie äh eine ein Gewinner von einer Million.
Und ähm du musst halt nur deine erste Dosis äh Impfstoff äh bekommen haben. Wobei das finde ich so ein bisschen so.
Na gut, besser als nichts.
Ja, ich meine, es ist es ist halt ein Angebot
an, auch eine bestimmte Bevölkerungsgruppe äh würde ich äh einfach mal sagen, äh ich denke mal, einen Großteil braucht äh diese Motivation nicht, aber einen Teil eben schon
so, das muss man halt einfach dann auch so sehen, ähm dass es halt einfach Leute gibt,
äh ja ich äh amerikanischer Komiker irgendwie, manchmal stellen sie sich vor, äh.
Wie äh dumm der Durchschnitt, der Durchschnittliche,
äh Mensch ist und dann stellen sie sich vor, dass die Hälfte noch deutlich dümmer ist. Ähm so und äh ja, für den,
Teil auf jeden Fall äh oder für einen für einen Teil äh der Leute, die offensichtlich nicht in der Lage sind, das äh nachzuvollziehen, äh,
dass das ihrem eigenen Schutz und Vorteil ist, äh wenn sie das tun. Ja, halt wegen einer Lotterie dann.
Hauptsache ja sind geimpft.
Hauptsache geimpft. Genau. Also ich hoffe, ihr lasst euch auch alle impfen, ohne ähm ohne Lotterie.
Ich würd's ja jedem gönnen, aber ich hab's nicht in der Hand. Ähm ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt hier einfach für diese Woche mal Schluss. Kürzere Sendung und äh sicherlich haben wir demnächst wieder mehr zu erzählen. Ansonsten, wenn ihr Lust habt.
Dienstag wieder Clubhaus Runde. Demnächst gibt's da wohl auch ein andere für und sollte sich das Problem dann auch erledigt haben. Noch ist nicht ganz so weit.
Dann machen wir hier nächste Woche wieder weiter und gucken mal, was ich getan hat mit all den Zahlen und all dem Kram. Ne? Also, sagen wir tschüss.